now with a hundred percent more mixture
marbles on the table 100 percent all of
them right here oh we're getting like a
little sad because the dogs are we're
going to London's and yeah we're gonna
be in London when you as a Washington's
we're recording it ahead of time just as
much time as possible with the chicken
yeah well chicken this episode is
brought to you by marbles it's also
brought to you by movement watches guys
classy design meets beautiful watches
for affordable prices check it out at M
VMT watches calm /jj and they'll give
you 15% off your first purchase they
have a wide selection of beautiful
watches that are at affordable prices
they look like they should cost you
about a half a grand but they don't and
they don't and they're light they're
light they're really awesome Nami
definitely also brought to you by frame
bridge frame bridge comm is a new easy
way to frame during frame things that
you love guys go to frame bridge calm
right now and you can upload pictures
you can even upload pictures directly
from your Instagram you can upload
pictures that you have and frame bridge
does all the work you can select from an
array of beautiful frames they will ship
to your house and then send it to your
mother for Mother's Day
Tennessee and mother for Mother's Day
all shipping is free their prices start
at $39 and now you can get 15% off if
you use products code Jenna Julie and
when you go to frame bridge calm Thank
You sponsors and you guys have seen my
watch the black yes Michael by the NBN
TIA
thanks so much I love mine he's has a
leather band I love the band of the band
Billy Ray you guys like are you are mic
stands oh this is me I guess we've had
that a couple of you notice that we had
in last podcast it's nice when there's
two people on seems like it fits better
but yeah yeah these are uh these are new
mixed especially if you're me and you
said well yeah yeah wherever you want
what I can go like this if I want to sit
like this and then it's not gonna be as
much of a problem yeah it's pretty great
yeah you can lean back with it can lean
[ __ ] forward as [ __ ] with it
okay don't make it weird I just made it
weird so no [ __ ] deal with it normal
male doing it mm-hmm so for today's
podcast we wanted to talk about a couple
things we're going to talk about
stranger things and we also wanted to
talk about the game inside that we just
finished playing a couple weeks ago on
the twitch stream both of them are very
intriguing but also like spoilers like
if you haven't watched stranger things
or played inside yeah that's planning on
doing either of those this is probably
not the podcast for you it goes without
saying even though you just said it if
you don't want to be spoiled click away
click game the way we can we talk about
everything real quick for you it's a Joe
Joe picked Jordan you leave a mess for
that [ __ ] spoilers spoilers entire
podcasters be called spoiler this is
gonna have come out maybe Bruce is dead
the entire time in success spoilers that
legitimately is a spoiler but over
decades been over like three weeks I
think since Jojo made that decision so
you're not it's okay like if you've got
spoiled now you probably weren't gonna
watch it anyway um yeah yeah so what
about it were you devastated for your
Robbie any Robbie fan no I liked Robbie
he was no I had him I had him winning
the whole thing
you're just being a troll any I'm not I
thought I'd throw that into spoiler
podcast yes but also Johnny this sucks
that's another spoiler spoiler we're
saying I I did a whole thing about this
in my in my vlog because I was [ __ ] up
by that episode and people were talking
about the challenge right and people
were like get Sara on your podcast
apparently she has her own podcast she's
dug brain something party brain candy
podcast yeah she's super dope I'll she
reminds me of my sister-in-law
contestants yeah yeah yeah you were
saying that the other day she does
pretty yeah super cool like maybe a
little more outgoing a little more
outspoken yeah but similar personality
definitely um well Sara hit us up you
can come on the podcast if you feel like
it any time you like
um alright let's start with strange
things whatever you were serving inside
I don't know so skip to the second half
you on watch strange things but we're
going to start with you played all of
inside on our twitch stream and those
streams are up on Jenna Julianne games
on YouTube if you wanted to realize the
channel where we got in all James yeah
you have so many ways to watch them on
the twitch app live or just in case you
wanted to catch all the shitty action of
us playing it's really not that shitty
it's kind of cool so your game your
honor
no the stream is awesome too oh yeah
it's not a shitty stream well especially
when we made them all those zombies
dance to Rihanna so inside is a really
cool game it's it's cool peachy you got
to go in your bed know peachy comp did
you come on mama don't don't do it
did you go and you flick ting parenting
it's the best way to make sure your
child goes off normal anyway uh for
those who haven't seen inside I mean you
can click into another window if you
have a second or and watch just kind of
get the vibe it or will explain to you
it's basically like a really dark
ominous kind of minimalistic game where
I made limbo right first yes yeah um and
there's theories on it if it's based in
the same universe as limbo my Raya but
anyway it's it's it's very weird it's
dark it's confusing at times and there's
a lot that happened that we've like
looked into and there's theories on why
it happened and so I guess we can just
start talking about what you got so I
wrote some stuff down but who is the boy
besides my daddy like is the boy a test
subject because if he's a test subject
II he's definitely gonna have this
conversation and I was gonna be like
talking about self err well you know if
he's a test subject he like why is he
more sentient why is he have these
emotions and qualities timeout because
when we finished playing the game
someone had typed in the chat that the
blob was the one controlling the boy
will give it leave art but we've already
at least established that
a theory of what the game I have a whole
section on the blob how I get to that
but so the boy is able to use his brain
or so it appears whereas the zombies
need to be controlled yeah you'll notice
initially we need the helmet to control
them but then later on we don't even
need the helmet they just follow us
differently subject so but the question
of is he a test subject is he one of
those drones just did he escape along
the way so he now has human qualities he
was able to kind of become aware of
what's going on peachie begging you been
huh come on any bet no Missy nice daddy
okay but I think that he I'm a believer
into the theory that the blob is
controlling the boy from the beginning
of the game okay and I guess we'll just
skip to the Bob Puckett yeah the blob is
controlling the boy and a Deary the blob
is controlling the game or the person
playing the game because you're in a
little platformer game you don't really
know what you're doing you have like a
vague outline of what you're supposed to
do so the blob is actually controlling
you as well so then the boy gets to the
end of the game jumps into the blob now
you're the blob and then by the time the
blob breaks free then the game's over
you can't you can't you can't play the
game anymore the blob doesn't need you
anymore so now you you're not even being
controlled by the blob so the boss don't
blob yeah so that's one of the theories
is like um you know the whole time each
level there's 90 levels each each scene
you're in like you're giving you're
giving really little information as to
what your goal is you just know that you
need to keep going towards a certain
direction you don't really know what
you're doing you just you're solving
these minis your puzzles but in the
grand scheme of things you don't really
know what what the whole goal is right
and so that would that would like
definitely back up the theory that the
blob is controlling you like he's just
right it is just driving you to come
free it yeah that's why I just said I
know I was I was backing you up
little research that I had done that
but what you'll notice though is that
once you've read the glob from the
factory and the game ends like there
there are two theories one you died on
impact and the blob is dead or you dead
and that's why no one can move or the
blob just doesn't need you anymore
like I just said and then you're just
kind of trapped inside of something that
had been controlling the whole time yeah
it's interesting though because like
there are moments where the boy
exhibits human behaviors right which
would lead you to believe that he's not
being controlled by Bob but he's really
just trying to escape the factory right
but there's an alternate ending though
that we looked up it shows the boy like
instead of going and getting into the
blob or whatever he goes down beneath
the tank and hits a switch that turns
off the tank or something like to kill
the blob or I don't [ __ ] know and the
boy just flops over dead and that's an
alternate ending so he therefore dies
which only supports the idea that you're
not a person yeah you have no human
maybe has some human qualities but no
you're not a person yeah and when the
machine turns off so does the boy so
he's definitely not a person I mean yeah
like I would guess that he was in the
line of subjects and he escaped
somewhere early on so he was able to
keep his human emotions his his
mortality he's evolved well no he's not
a zombie
well no but like maybe he's he's sorry
uh maybe he's like he's he got out early
enough like you notice he jumps after
off of a cliff a hundred feet down he'll
break his legs and die if a zombie does
that they'll just kind of flop down and
stand back up
he's an evolved version of a zombie test
subject that has more consciousness or
because the dogs will also chase him and
not the zombies yeah or he's the
opposite of evolved maybe he's not
evolved into a drone so he was more of a
human before he got okay so he's some
sort of hybrid yeah yeah yeah I think
that's what people we've established
that okay I'm just trying to
all the subjects here no I know but um
okay it's a long hair curl underwater
the mermaid yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] so I
looked up some things on her and AH the
scene where you get like the rebirth is
is what it's called what she drives
power to breathe underwater
so she drags you all the way down and
she stops chasing you yeah
the theory is every single time she had
tried to get you before that and killed
you underwater
she had just failed at her goal of
bringing you down to give you that
rebirth right
you knew that yeah god we read the same
article um well but you alright but so
that explains why every single time
you're underneath water after that she
doesn't bother you because she was
trying to help you right and then when
you yeah you go in under water after
that no one's chasing you because now
you can breathe underwater it supports
the theory though that everything that
you run into along the way is only
helping you or the blob is helping you
trying to get to the blob yeah so the
mermaid needs to give you the ability to
breathe underwater in order to get to
the blob like then maybe the blob is
controlling the mermaid - yeah I'm I'm
in the school of thought that the blob
is controlling everything what about all
the workers at the factory yeah he's not
controlling them what's their deal are
they just like are they human actual
human beings going to work at this fact
yeah they were they were taking zombies
and doing weird science [ __ ] and making
a blob but it has a level of
consciousness so it cares and it hates
being in that tank and it wants to break
free so find somebody to mentally
control because you know it like all the
people were zombies knowing the blob
can't mentally connect with anyone to
set it free so it finds this boy that
still has some level of consciousness
that it can tap into that can come all
the way to the blob and free it hmm yeah
that's just crazy to think about ions
like um like I really want to see what
the outside world is like because all
you see is the factory and then you get
outside and then the game's over like
I'd love to see if like any of this
click continues outside like if there
are there are more droughts so there are
more people being like manipulated or
there's more like mermaids in the what
an ocean Outsiders all only exist in the
factory I think it only exists in the
factory hmm not well I guess the
discussion is over
I think that the blob is controlling
everything and then when the game is
over
the blob is finally free and it's just
chilling by the lake now it's got to
figure out what to do I think it speaks
more to like society as a whole and in
the future
if you're doing weird science
experiments like talk about cloning
you're talking about stem-cell [ __ ] like
when you're when we're creating these
artificial things out of living material
when it comes to a point when it has a
consciousness at what point is it just
inhumane to do this you know like say
cloning people was the thing right and
you get all of these little Julian's and
all these little Jenna's and you're like
oh these are just our clones but those
are living breathing consciousness yeah
you know so they created a blob out of
other zombies who have no consciousness
maybe but when you add them all together
they do have a consciousness where is
the ethical line with that so I think
the point of the game maybe just a
sterile area there want to throw a
theory out there is that when you cross
that ethical line you need to take that
beings consciousness into consideration
because look how far it went to go and
save itself because it's in pain and
doesn't want to do that hmm I'll give
this whole Factory you have all these
security measures but when it comes to
like giving something human emotions and
human feelings like that will overpower
any sort of experiment you're doing
because that becomes I don't know
at I think it just I'm not I don't know
about that I just think that it poses
the question of when you create a
science experiment that has a
consciousness that you need to think
about what you're doing yeah because all
of these people are just taking these
zombies who have no feelings no emotions
you know they're all [ __ ] up some have
no head and they have no like clearly
they don't care what's going on they put
them all together it's I'm trying to
think of a plausible sort of scenario it
could draw it in it's like if you took a
bunch of pencils and you put them all
together and then all of a sudden the
pencil started feeling something this
giant group of pencils started feeling
something it would be hard for most
people to be like that pencil has
feelings what are you doing because that
one's like it's [ __ ] it's a bunch of
[ __ ] pigs yeah these are great but
these are like almost like a hollowed
out bodies like these are like they have
the semblance of a human being to start
with so it's like they're not pencils
they're like okay feathers no it's over
downloads and all of a sudden started
feeling feels like mannequins or
something that resembles a person you
know I mean like initially like you have
this factory line of all these bodies
who may have just been people at one
point and you've put them through these
process of getting them stripped down to
literally just kind of be drones but
like physically they still sort of
embody a person and so even though
they're nothing like mentally and they
have no ability to think or do anything
for themselves they still I don't know
I'm saying like they still resemble a
person so when you put them all together
and they start getting feelings again
like yes that should that should change
the way you think of them but it's also
like they were also like my opinion is
that they were people before anything
started mm-hmm like they weren't just
created in a factory I think that they
were a stripped down brainwashed and
like disabled well yeah I'm not sure
that they were created somewhere they
clearly seem to be people that were then
zombified or they could be created I
mean I don't know I think that they were
zombified I think
I just think the overarching idea of the
game is suppose an ethical question yeah
that's fair I think the whole mermaid
thing is also another thing where it's
like the whole time you're just
desperately trying to escape it and get
away from it because it's terrifying in
a student looks like ice trying to just
drown you underwater but it eventually
is the reason you're able I mean to be
fair the [ __ ] broke the window inside
of our submarine in the most horrifying
way and dragged us out of in that
submarine was dope she could have
knocked in like mild something that was
like I'm trying to help you she could
have held up a sign she had a lot of
other options she didn't have to do it
that way yeah but maybe she was just
doing this [ __ ] in a dire way because
the circumstances were she's crazy and
she needed to get you down to that
machine so you could finally breathe
underwater because she didn't know when
you were going to escape and once you
lose you because she's lost you if you
if you're the mermaid and this little
boy is it trying to run away because
you're gross but you don't know how to
speak English you don't know how to like
this EU diplomat you're just chasing
this mother [ __ ] you have one goal of
helping him he doesn't know you're
helping him but in your mind if he
escapes then you're like I am living
down here forever nothing's ever going
to change the blog will never get freed
like I don't know what the blob getting
freed has to do with the Merman but it
has to do something like there is a
cause and effect there so because of the
blob escape the mermaid definitely has a
different future than if the blonde blob
haven't had an escape so she's trying to
at all cost get you out get you down
give you the power to be reborn as a
person who can breathe on her water or
as a thing that can be breathed
underwater and that's what she did and
so every time she dragged you down and
failed and killed you that was like a
failed attempt hmm she's still a [ __ ]
though I think she's kind of [ __ ] she
could have been nicer but then if she
was nicer it might have gotten that not
gotten the job done no no she had lots
of options she's a [ __ ]
she was looking she was trying to drag a
boy with no face underwater that's I
mean and nobody we're like this he's
here
terrible do the workers have faces yeah
they look like they do they have like
glasses and [ __ ] on gays they don't know
faces I don't know I'd have to go back
and look hmm that's interesting what do
you think the point of making a blob
full of zombie people in parsa's I don't
know to make some super zombie that you
can control and destroy stuff why do you
know what in water so they were like
soaking those people upside down zombie
parts the look to me it looked like they
were trying to prep them to them become
a part of the blob and then underwater
in this big giant tank is the blob
hooked up to things but it's underwater
I think they're trying to create a super
weapon monster full of blob like I think
they were going to they were testing
constantly on these these humans humans
like zombies they were causally testing
running tests keeping them locked up in
this facility you know putting them on
assembly lines the like seemingly like
there was an end goal of making them all
one weapon I don't know why else they
would put a tank with all that
everything inside of it especially all
the security they had without having
some evil intentions of using them as a
weapon in some capacity even if it is
just to just for tests like just like in
you know cross over to stranger things
like how they how they're having all
these experiments done in this lab and
it's so secret because no one can ever
know about the [ __ ] that they're doing
you know because they're doing [ __ ]
that's wrong and people can't know about
it and it's it's for bad reasons but
they'll do it anyway because they can
well yeah I mean isn't it sort of the
same thing is that people are doing
science experiments and all of a sudden
you lose control of your science
experiment no that's definitely um
that's a huge theme in this in this game
well the difference between maybe
stranger things and inside is that we
don't know or we might not even be shown
ever what the consciousness or feelings
of the aliens are yeah there are shadow
things dem Accord yet because if all of
a sudden at the end of the game you were
like oh my god the demagogue is so sweet
and wonderful and has a consciousness
now I feel weird about the whole
thing yeah they're just they're made out
to be a linear monster they're just a
monster mm-hmm
yeah I mean I it's just one of those
things that makes you think it's like
wild you know try just like it's [ __ ]
up I could never go to work being like
yeah dude totally me and a giant blob
full of zombies today for science you
know well yeah but you also would not
have been able to live with yourself
working at the agency and stranger
things yeah no of course not this is
like why I didn't become a vet I like
all I ever wanted to do when I was a kid
was be a vet until I realized what a vet
actually does and I was like count me
the [ __ ] out I do not want to poke
animals that I like with needles like
put him to sleep and you want to do it
[ __ ] the opposite of being a vet yeah I
wanna do the opposite which is just pet
them and kiss them all day I want to be
a vet Bias all the doctoring you know
what I mean do you still care for them
you're just not healing them yeah well
I'm just healing them all the opposite
of that someone who just kills animals
because of that muscle dance [ __ ] no
let's kill animals too yeah but they
their goal is to save animals
you never know the opposite you never
know you can't say that for sure you
never know mm-hmm are you deep in
thought right mom I'm still deep in that
thought no you know how they're like did
you ever notice that during the game you
obviously had control of yourself and
the surrounding items and things or
whatever but there were also moments in
the game where you really just felt like
you were being controlled by the game
like only having so many options to do
things yeah or like you know where the
water shifted and the gravity was upside
down or like things like that where
you're just like I'm kind of just I'm
just kind of the pawn here right you're
playing someone rule someone's world the
universe that was like maybe all of
those moments were calculated to remind
you that you are not controlling
yourself may
the blob is you don't mean like those
those moments make me really feel like
we are not in our own you know in
control of us I mean that I saw some
theories about it being placed before
the game of limbo or something like that
because of the gravitational poles or
whatever and different things bad boy
finish limbo or you've played it though
I played a lot of it but I didn't finish
it so I don't I don't know what is limbo
like it's sort of blowing my phone yeah
it's like that except it's black and
white and should be like sort of creepy
and just dark uh but more it's far more
simple than it's more like Badlands than
mad land than it is inside okay so
there's badlands those inside and here's
them though um no I would bat éramos
even more simple than bad land really
yeah
okay or at least as far as I got it's
just black and white and it's very
simple hmm it's almost two-dimensional
looking to him yeah you also know
there's no concept of time and inside
how do you know that well there's I mean
at least to you there's no concept of
time you don't see the Sun Rise or set
you don't see any like basically if you
could either to stand in the level where
you could see the the assembly line
going in the background if you were to
stand there for hours it nothing would
change like there's no concept of time
everything is just happening it's a
factory you know yeah but there's all
there's time there in a dimension where
there is time you know that well because
it you played the game I'm saying
there's a reference as a player of the
game of how much time has gone by
because there you can't see Sun and you
can't have any reference as to how much
time has gone by there is like a
space-time continuum and it is happening
linearly gain yeah yeah okay but
external the game though you don't know
yeah you don't know yeah it's like you
can just be in the game and check your
movement watch and see what time it is
oh my god Juliana all that
and when the man watches our sponsor
this week everyone make sure for your
watch needs Co check out and it watches
they have really really sweet like I'm
telling you like these when I first saw
them they look really expensive they
look luxury and they are luxury but they
are affordable and they start at prices
that you you would definitely want to
spend on a watch because it's quality
they have tons of interchangeable color
schemes to match your summer outfit or
move for whatever day you're going for
that you know with that look with
genuine leather band three hand quartz
movement and stainless steel case
movement delivers classic watches for
prices that's honestly a steel steel
with the steel steel steel good joke
these watches they look like they should
be four or five hundred bucks but
they're not they keep them at a perfect
price point starting at just $150 which
is enough to know that you're paying for
something solid all right now guys go
check out their social media pages and
see what you like because if you're
impressed this as I am
you will join the movement today go to M
VMT watches comm /jj and you get 15% of
your entire purchase with movement and
then you'll be matching us hell yeah
and then if you love your movement watch
that much you just take a picture of it
and upload it to frame bridge you can
get something frames on the internet all
the work done for you where you just get
it sent to your house in a beautiful
frame
there's ours over there grab bars the
frame from frame breeze that's so cute
it's pretty it's so nice awfully Freddie
um they have all sorts of selections of
frames you can get I actually was going
to go with something like really plain
but then I saw this one and I was like
it looks like we're on the sandy beach
or yeah it's got like a beach or like a
um like a vacation on a sailboat vibe I
really like it vacation on a sailboat
yeah yeah so my thought why not be on
the sailboat you guys what's cool is you
can preview your image in any frame
style they'll do a little mock-up for
you on the website so you can see what
you're getting Wow
they send you a prepaid if you have the
also frame items so if you have like
tickets or jersey or a paper or
something
physical that you have that means a lot
to you they can frame that for you they
can even send you a prepaid package to
ship it in or you can send it yourself
you can even upload directly from
Instagram Instagram and get it framed go
to frame bridge right now and you're
never going to go to frame store I'm
telling you it's the future of framing
stuff all the shipping is free and their
prices start at just $39 right now go to
frame bridge comm use promo code Jenna
Julian for 15% off your first order I'll
kill ya expose issue sponsors marble you
having fun up here
mumble you on the podcast you want to
come make a noise for us I love when he
sits up here with us well well that
right wow wow wow wow wow
sir oh he's asleeping he's always sleepy
bro what do you do besides sleep that
your whole life makes that noise he's an
old man he's gone all right hey I'm
sorry to bug you bud
he's a good little old man you just so
handsome and I like to say hello to you
on the occasion I don't want to leave
him I get so sad when we travel and we
don't have the dogs yeah it's sad I know
anyways I miss I'm sure you move on to
stranger things yeah but you want let's
go change things okay I'm buddy so just
like everyone and their mom right now we
are in love with stranger things we
watched it in like 20 hours and it was
amazing it was really her so it was
really [ __ ] great really [ __ ]
great first thing though I'm realist
first thing okay thank you yeah I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
um I saw everybody on social media
talking about it as I'm sure everyone
has and people are like shooting so
great so great so great and I didn't
look up anything about it all I thought
was the little poster with the red
letters it said stranger things and I
was like I know there's kid actors and
that's about all that I knew and then we
started watching it and I was
terrified it was [ __ ] scary is
legitimately scary nobody said that
beforehand jazz Jenna can't handle
scared I get [ __ ] scared and you
needed like I needed a heads up no you
were like you were under the impression
that like oh it's mainstream like
everyone watches it so it was like
change things is so good oh my god I'm
just scared I want to watch that so then
I sit there and I'm like what like the
opening scene yeah I mean this is
[ __ ] terrifying
there are jump scares that's the thing
like yeah no matter how unscared you are
things jump scares are gonna get you and
they're terrifying and you know those
noises and the coming out of the wall
like it had a lot of really dark vibes
of like things that you'd see in horror
movies so that's something I
legitimately agree with that we didn't
expect I was scared but I like that they
used it in moderation it didn't just
become like a horror series I am there
were moments of being scary but it felt
like it they actually could so well and
they were trying to like portray this
the other side and they've done such a
good job of painting that picture for
you and I love like I just like I
preview so much visually about that show
the way that they decorate the sets of
the other side comparatively shadow and
oh my god it's so cool like little
things like the floating particles I
mean everything is just it's just really
really cool really beautiful show so
I've compiled some of your questions I
went on Twitter at Jenna Julianne pod on
Twitter account and I said guys if we're
going to do a stranger things podcast
what questions do you have for us to
discuss and you a lot of you guys left
awesome questions and I wrote them all
down in and out so I don't have your ATS
on here but thank you all who submitted
questions I appreciate it
why don't we just start with the first
question god how is 11 connected to the
monster mm if at all I don't think that
11 is per se connected to the monster I
think that the same company whatever
that [ __ ] place is love they were
developing the ability to contact like
to use telekinesis and to use make
contact yeah just her psychic abilities
and to connect with
the shadow realm or whatever and that
because she did that she made a portal
that's how they got into whatever the
[ __ ] but I don't think she's connected
to the monster I think that she's
definitely her only connection is that
she is she's the phone yeah she's like
elephant I agree with that I don't think
she has some deep-rooted connection but
though I mean even um
I mean I you never know okay here's
another question that I really wanted
okay is there only one monster no I say
no that was that was the most laughable
part to me about the whole thing like is
this monster like a Santa Claus of
monsters he's just everywhere at once no
of course not there has to be well they
made a lot of like references to
possibly not that not being the case
when remember when they saved the boy
will and at the end and he's in the
[ __ ] Shadow Realm and whatever and
they pull that thing out of him that was
like a living little tentacle yeah like
there's clearly who's got him whenever
there's another demit that's like saying
someone accidentally stepped into the
human dimension where we are and you saw
one Yemeni [ __ ] no but I think
completely there's not one what a
horrible assumption to make that there's
only one yeah
horrible yeah I'm trying to think of a
specific moment in the show when one
person was being a or was interacting
with a monster at the same time when
there was hints like for instance like
remember when he's in his little Hut in
the Shadow Realm yeah and hold on and
he's just sitting there and he's like
singing to himself and then he hears the
monster run by right wasn't that around
the same time as as when Nancy and
what's-his-name were trying to bait the
monsters at the house like I felt like
there couldn't if they couldn't just be
one monster I mean there's a lot of I
just feel like there's a homo sir yeah
fair to move on yeah okay why does no
one give a [ __ ] about barb I'm saying
the same thing no one care before during
or after she dies they're all looking
for will right the little boy and no one
gives a [ __ ] that barb is dead by the
way I can't
that's right well yeah you did like her
parents aren't they're flipping out like
nobody's slipping out there everyone's
just so excited we all will back and
knit air but Barb's [ __ ] dick Barb's
dead Nancy has like a moment of being
sad then she's back for Steve ever he's
good right way we'll get to that but
like her car was still there like nobody
was there so like good day so far it's
sad for the shot before the I think the
lab people moved the car or something
yeah um when she's getting drug into the
pool or dragged into the pool into the
Shadow Realm and she's screaming and
Nancy's having sex with Steve or
whatever yeah right at that moment when
she was being dragged in I was like oh
she's dead like there's no way like
she's not surviving the chatroom because
of the fashion in which she was brought
into it there was blood which we noticed
was the first time that they attracted
the blood and went the way she was being
dragged in that pole like there's no way
she's escaping for will for everyone
else who had been to the Shadow Realm
there were reasons that they could have
not died but for barb I was like oh
she's dead and then she was dead right
and she her face looked all shook up
America well yeah so um 11 was in the
the kiddie pool full of salt floating
around you know telecommunicator with
the other side and she sees [ __ ] barb
that is like dead and covered in like
alien maggots and she's just like gone
gone or whatever she said about barb and
everyone just looks around and is like
Oh bummer
- [ __ ] and then she finds will and
they're like is it well I'm like nobody
I mean like nobody cares they really put
all their eggs the show it and in a
whole thing like they put their eggs
into the wheel basket and so like when
they when they like so soft like glaze
over the fact that other human being
child had died so [ __ ] can I say those
also what like going off-topic for one
second sort of good I feel like the the
show is fantastic and the what are the
two brother the duffer brothers is that
right my saying that uh yeah it's been a
couple weeks something like that the
brothers that made the show oh yeah yeah
other Creators yeah you can totally tell
that this was their baby for years that
they had been writing this story for
years that they love that they finally
[ __ ] made it you know what
I don't know that this is what it seems
like but it seems like they've been
working on this story for a while for a
hot second I mean I will be interested
to see where the series goes in the
future because like the pacing of the
show is so fantastic the way that they
took it's like time to reveal it sound
really well done
you know so the first like six episodes
you're still in so much suspense exactly
don't you don't have your views to see
if they believe that style of not like
playing their cards all at once in this
right school because you know who
there's a lot of other mysteries to be
uncovered in the future you can take the
story in a lot of different directions
but are they gonna lose that magic from
this first season yeah
because maybe they're we don't know
maybe under a time crunch to write a
second season or maybe they've already
written I heard today from a friend that
October is won the second season comes
up oh so it's already that's what I just
heard from one person it could be
completely false but I just percent
Cheech it sir his name is you just does
he work at Netflix no as one of my jutsu
as they were saying like it comes out in
October and I was like blown away cuz I
was like they probably but didn't this
season just come out yeah but they could
have gotten done with production a long
time ago and just started the next
season right away I'm just saying like
this is what I've heard it could be
completely false but it can also have
some truth I wouldn't put my eggs in
that basket anyone that's listening
I would put my execute in that time
Julian's friend from jujitsu said
October so get excited because Julian's
friend Jesse says deal with it alright
um he's will now forever connected to
the other side and if so in what
capacity I say yes because he had that
tentacle inside of his body and then he
spit up some weird little leech into the
sink and then flashed into the Shadow
Realm I he's definitely connect there's
a couple of possibilities right the one
is that it's like an alien scenario or
whatever where once it gets inside of
your body you and out of the host and
then you become the alien or you breed
the alien in some capacity like maybe
him spitting out that that little leech
is now that's going to grow into be an
alien
in some way he's the host you know so
either he turns into an alien or has the
ability to go back and forth or he is
able to breed little aliens but I said
he is connected for sure I feel like he
him getting to the point of having the
alien literally inside not the alien the
monster demagogue literally inside of
him
bonds him to the Shadow Realm in a way
that only someone who has been literally
like infiltrated physically by the
shadow bomb can have so I'm not saying
that he's definitely going to end up in
the Shadow Realm and die but he's
definitely like he is more connected to
shall roam than any human being ever
well yeah like he's almost as connect to
the genre as the demagogue but he's not
there yet he's just like partially so
I'm agreeing with you I just think he's
he's more connected yeah like for good
yeah is 11 alive I think 11 in live why
I don't think that using your
telekinesis could ever make you just
explode into another dimension so where
did you go I mean I don't know but I
don't think that she's dead cuz it felt
like but I don't think he's there either
but I felt like a sacrifice
well yeah but ok so what's his face the
deputy sheriff whatever the [ __ ] put a I
don't know I still don't know what to
make of that scene cuz member right
after everything unraveled they get all
this closure waffle bit the guy goes the
chef II whoops oh my god deputy shut up
I forget his name - um so he gets in the
car with those guys yeah whatever the
[ __ ] and they clearly tell him something
about 11:00 or I don't [ __ ] know
because then he's putting these Eggo
waffles inside of a box in the woods
yeah which indicates that something is
going on for Levin and that she still
needs some food which leads into my next
question of one of the stipulations of
the sheriff's deal with a laboratory
because it clearly has the dealer I
we're still talking about eleven being a
lot yeah no I know but I'm just saying
when you said he got into the
like it there the car whatever like it
yeah just reminded me of that but yeah I
don't know I think it was just so that
he doesn't talk anymore but maybe he by
some chance found out some information
about 11 and still cares about her and
wanted to make sure that she wasn't you
definitely think that like you you don't
doubt at all that him putting the
waffles there is a genuine like he knows
it's going to help her it's not some
sort of like emotional thing that he's
doing to like feel good and put the
waffles there to remember 11:00 it's
like actually like Elevens alive yeah uh
and potentially she transported into the
Shadow Realm permanently by using her
telekinesis at though I would him
putting the waffles in she's in the
Shadow Realm maybe she can get to it
somehow wouldn't he have to put it in
the shadow room
maybe that spot is like a hot spot for
the shot so I'm saying maybe she can get
to somehow do me yeah I agree with you
but I was like I don't think eleven is
dead at all just out of pure logic she
was a fantastic actress really good
she's not just gonna disappear
there's no way yeah what is the deal
that he struck i don't just don't talk
about it and then what he's clearly
being given insider information now all
maybe he's not maybe he just thinks
eleven is there or he's been talking to
her with what two faces [ __ ]
Christmas lights um
well is uh is the bad man is he dead
what happened to him like did he die
who's the bad man the father of eleventh
the guy who runs the whole show hmm is
he dead look it gives you reason to
believe you died I think he's dead he
got killed by a demagogue but that's
what he said so and he's in the Shadow
Realm just chillin there's one of the
two he's either dead or in the shower
cuz he's not an arm well if a legends in
the Shadow Realm and so is the bad man
yeah that's what I'm saying like that
could be a great storyline right there
but the under controlling [ __ ] from the
shadow I personally think I'm gonna take
a leap and say the bad man is dead be
cuttin or whatever zooms but because
doctor daddy because the way the
laboratories people
like after that whole fight in the
school when like the woman died and dr.
Brennan seemed to have has died like
what it seems like the whole dynamic
between the lab and the sheriff shifted
and he now has a deal with them they not
respect each other they know they're
cordial they're not like fighting
anymore he they're not arresting him but
all that could happen if the bad man was
in the Shadow Realm that's that's that's
true that's true
you got me that's true because he
remember how 11 made the woman and all
those other people cry blood yeah
therefore if the demagogue came he would
kill all of those crystals they were
bleeding but when the demagogue got the
bad man there was no blood or all didn't
make him cry blood he came in after yeah
yeah he could be alive in the Shadow
Realm like will because when they were
abducted there was no presence of blood
possibility because I mean think about
this I right so if the people that it
abducts that there that are bleeding the
demagogues think their food but the
people that it abducts for seemingly no
reason and then they stay in the shallow
room and don't get killed maybe they're
bringing them there to be hosts like
will to then get the demagogue inside of
their bodies and whatever it's really
good theory right so really good theory
because there's like as that's there
that's an agenda that would clearly
benefit the demagogues right so if it
doesn't think that you're food if you're
not bleeding so it brings you there to
then be a host so the bad man is
basically just arriving will to be the
host he got him to be a host
they were like keeping him in there
right we still don't know what host
means yeah but maybe that's an
explanation as to why the demagogue
kills some people or tries to kill some
people and doesn't kill other people
because the very first episode when it
abducts will or whatever why isn't it
why isn't real dead it's not because he
ran away from the demagogue it calls you
into the Shadow Realm you got it wants
to kill you or it had plans for him
other than killing her right yeah yeah
definitely
all right so now possibly the most
important question of the series why is
Nancy with Steve again
what the birds too true I don't [ __ ] I
know that honestly confounds me because
like it's like now one friend that just
won't [ __ ] listen to you no matter
what you say to them they just she gonna
make her own choices
II got a list he's changed no he has it
he's not changed maybe he'll change for
six months
and then he's gonna go back to his old
[ __ ] my favorite my favorite part that
Steve was exposed exposed Steve again
was when was when he walks in and
they're trying to trap the demagogue and
he's like holy [ __ ] what's happening and
then he just is made to look like the
biggest idiot and in kind of pansy
throughout that whole thing mm-hmm right
and Will's brothers just like studing it
out killing the demagogue
you know [ __ ] killing [ __ ] and that
was my favorite part cause it made Steve
look so powerless in the shadow realm
where in the world he was this big shot
but then in the you know in the real
[ __ ] that was happening he's kind of
useless yeah and um will 11 ever meet
her mother and it will it make the
mother talk I think 11 will meet her
mother and I don't think it's gonna make
the mother clock talk I think it's just
going to make it weird I think they will
meet whether in this room or possibly
the shadow realm because maybe the the
disabled mother will get dragged into
the Shadow Realm and I think what I
think happened will happen is [ __ ] when
I think what happened is she's going to
end up in the Shadow Realm with 11
talked to 11 in the Shadow Realm get
back into the real life and then
struggle with talking again but
eventually figure it out
bold prediction cotton the steel pans
out is the teacher still safe what who
was that guy with the moustache who
helps them with the radio and was a cool
guy that does what well what happened
that was making it seem like he wasn't
safe um he was on that date right with
that girl and he answered the phone
there was something that happened that
made you think that he was in trouble
I don't remember oh well I guess nothing
was it the blonde lady the ominous
ladies showed up his house something
like that yes that was it I think he's
okay he was pretty cool things in fact I
like him why would you keep this door to
curiosity locked I know I love him but
he's gonna die he's deaf ah that's
terrible um make him good well I guess
we kind of covered Muslim is that does
the sheriff now have quick access to the
other side I thought there's a question
hmm
I think he's quick access I think he has
access the quicker than the average Joe
well he knows where the main portal is
yeah yeah I mean now that he has access
because of his deal does he do is he
able to just kind of jump back and forth
no nor would anyone want to just jump
back and forth between the Shadow Realm
in the regular realm first of all I have
some live parties down there the
atmosphere is toxic so it's not a good
idea for people just be jumping and
chillin uh-huh and we know that there's
multiple portals there's one in that
building but then there's also the one
that Nancy's dumbass just [ __ ]
crawled into into that tree I will never
get over that scene like what the [ __ ]
are you doing I hate you I hate you
you know she had to get rescued a F
whatever but there's multiple portals
yeah
I don't like anyone's just gonna be
jumping back and forth yeah I don't see
a reason for him to do it either since
they just put the AYGO officers I have a
question for you so because one thing
that the show keeps showing is that the
portals keep growing like you know those
little slow shots like in the shed where
like every time or every place someone
is taken by a demagogue it seems to open
up one of those little portals right
yeah like in the chalkboard or in the
wall yeah right
is it a possibility that as this world
progresses everything just becomes a
shadow world wars overcome or our entire
world is just like covered in portals
and access between bloodlines I don't
think one can overtake the other I think
they are they will always coexist okay
but like so everywhere that we are
though there's portal there's potential
to be portals there's not portals
already there's only portals when they
make them right so but I mean if this
continues on you can imagine a place
where there's so many portals or at
least easy access from all over the
place yeah yes I don't know what your
question is I guess my question is do
you think that's a possibility I think I
think a portal can kind of end up
literally in any specific point in in
our world to take you to the Shadow
Realm
I don't think the location of the portal
matters I just think the reason for that
portal existing that's all that needs to
happen but okay what do you think the
reason for the portal existing is
because I say it's whenever a demagogue
comes in whatever the location that it
came in from create support so you think
when they create a portal that portal is
always a portal it's then it stays like
that what how do you explain otherwise
why there's a portal near the tree or
wireless sensors portal in the waller or
why there's a portal yeah I mean maybe
once a portals created that spot is
forever a working portal right okay so
go down that line do you think there
will be a time where there's just
portals all over the place yeah or that
there will be a time when when you can
sort of seamlessly or not even
consciously travel back and forth the
way the will did
last seen when he's going back and forth
between the shadow realm and reality I
think the eventually people are going to
be able to go back and forth very
quickly because of the overwhelming
amount maybe not even on purpose or not
in participant or be fit because you're
a house like well that's [ __ ] crazy
anyways my brain hurts my brain hurts -
alright well let's finish off what are
your predictions for next season well
first of all I don't know if there's
going to be a next season
my prediction first is that there will
be a next season well October according
to your friend from jujitsu
he's right my prediction is that 11 is
not dead
um okay we're going to see some sort of
storyline with will having this ability
to travel back and forth between the
shadow realm and the rail realm and it's
either going to be helpful or something
really [ __ ] terrifying I think it's
going to be helpful hmm um but he's
going to have some sort of trouble with
the fact that maybe he's now connected
to demagogues okay or he turns into a
down guard that would be lit as [ __ ] if
all of a sudden one scene wills face
just opened up like that flower and now
he's just a person dem Accord epidemic
gorg I think a third party is going to
be introduced in the next season right
now there's humans and demagogues who's
our realm and the shadow realm I think
some third element will be introduced oh
good prediction like the game like duh
okay what was the other one there
playing with it was like a Medusa with
fire breathing fire [ __ ]
oh yeah the game they're playing which
is basically a period of the whole
series oh yeah yeah I think there's
gonna be a third element oh that's my
biggest pretty yeah are you get that
we're base this is basically Jumanji is
what you're saying
no three L's yeah oh yeah yeah well
there you have it's Jim Angie though
it's not Jumanji it's just money I'm not
sure but they're playing a board game
and everything that they're playing in
the board game comes in real life except
one board iam is not in Janaka for new
users
I'm kind of name is it's a parallel you
know but in Jumanji the board is just on
this penis or denied discreet my god
in Jumanji for the point in Jumanji the
board you know is a literal
interpretation of what happened I know
NASA mice in this series the board game
is just kind of a parallel it's not
exactly the same there are a lot of
parallels with all the things that
they're doing with their moves and their
characters and their you know locations
on the board and the flipping over the
board being the the chatter on that
there's all just parallels there it's
not a you don't I mean it's not yet no
one was saying that all these things
that it's like Jamaa you said it is
German oh my god
I want to see the other characters that
they use in the board game like [ __ ]
Jumanji tom is not a mangy nobody said
this is a literal Jumanji remake rewind
the tape you said that a second would it
be called Jimmy James and whoopee falls
too much G 2k16 Netflix subscribe this
conversation is over well with that
movie because I get you man
just go stand as those demagogue is this
hopefully you guys enjoyed the
discussion on stranger things inside you
know obviously there will be more
podcasts on stranger things as the new
seasons come out and more things happen
because NASA such an exception show that
I love and I can't believe we are so
lucky to have been grace it's really
really it's just one of those shows that
are lucky you left thinking about it and
yes way possible so huge fans of strange
things can't wait to see what's next and
right now we're in London so we're here
but we're in London so if you're in
London and say hi to us if you see us
we'll be hanging around for a couple
more days and then heading back home
check out frame frame bridge get your
stuff framed online very easy and check
out movement watches for sweet sweet
watches and check out baubles Fah Wow
also giving you the but right now uhé
little guy oh thanks I think he likes as
a cue
this he needed some attention this is
how we used to sit at work all the time
yeah that's all use that up sit peach
that my work remember she was tiny
enough to Samba yeah we love it we love
you guys very much
hit us in the comments with your
thoughts on stranger things inside you
and also Jumanji because why not do not
comment you will be banned from the
channel if you write the word now you
are here
Jumanji just do this emoji no alright
guys have a great week we'll see you
next time
hi I am